do you think that margaret ferrer should
resign as an mp
i think she should resign as an mp i
think she has lost the trust of our
constituents and i think
in terms of the way that we have to deal
with this global pandemic we need to
send out the message that people must
comply with the rules and for anybody to
break the rules
it's putting people at risk for a member
of parliament to break rules in such a
negligent and haphazard way putting the
lives in the health of
workers at risk and for people who work
on trains and in parliament
is really unforgivable and we need to
send a very strong message that this
will not be tolerated
so if if you get your way and she does
resign they'll of course be a
by-election
what would labour's position be on a
second independence referendum
in that by-election well our position is
absolutely clear the scottish executive
committee which is the ruling
committee of the scottish labor party
passed and reaffirmed
its position back in may and that
position is to
go into the election next year against
independence as we always have been
and against the second independent
referendum and come out of that election
with exactly the same position
but if the snp win uh the
majority next year's scottish parliament
elections would they have a mandate for
another referendum
well i think these hypothetical
questions are something that we should
be putting on the background or during
this global pandemic your first
questions on
whether or not an smp mp would be
spreading the virus across the united
kingdom by
traveling to and from parliament and
that's what the scottish people want us
to concentrate at the moment they want
us to go into that election you know we
have a post-covered recovery plan they
want us to come out with that election
trying to
sort the economy sort of people's jobs
and protect their livelihoods and to
consistently have these
hypothetical questions so kirsten has
gone into
the leadership of the labour party with
its new leadership and said quite
clearly that he wants to be leader of
the whole of the united kingdom
in 2024 he wants to make sure that
scotland isn't independent and he
doesn't want a second independence
referendum so those are pretty clear
positions i think all these
hypotheticals we need to move on is not
the priorities of the scottish people
and if i could just very quickly say
that in the recent poll and release the
last two polls actually
a second independence referendum just
made it into the top 10 when you add
those who desperately wanted one to
those who desperately didn't want one so
it's not the priorities of the scottish
people
and we have to concentrate on those and
that's what we're doing in the election
that's what we'll continue to do after
the election
you know you can kind of criticize us
for not asking enough about coronavirus
for asking about scottish independence
for
asking hypothetical questions but i feel
like the problem is that
if journalists feel that they're not
quite clear what labour's position is
in response to this question then
they're just going to keep asking
the question again kier starman back in
january so the snp
will have a mandate for another
referendum if they win next year he
added this is a question for scotland
and the people of scotland
if there's a majority it has to be
looked at in westminster
it feels as if you're not being straight
what would the position be
well this isn't a fight for the labour
party to have we won't be
empowered at westminster come may 2021
unless there is some
kind of general election before then i
doubt that will it happen
with you at all on something that is
such an important issue
and therefore kirsten has been pretty
clear he wants to take forward
a constitutional convention that looks
at a federal estate across the united
kingdom he wants to
look at how the house of lords operates
he wants a new constitutional settlement
going into the
2024 general election that's what will
be in the labour party manifesto the
labour party
couldn't be clearer in fact the reason
that we're in some of the
difficulties in terms of electoral
difficulties in scotland is because we
are clear on this principal position
we're against independence
and against the second independent
referendum and i really do think that
this is uh
couldn't be clearer and if you look at
douglas ross and in terms of the new
scottish
conservative leader he said quickly
though that many in his own party
don't believe in the union and really
the biggest threat to the united kingdom
at the moment
even more than any nationalist in fact
is the conservative unionist party with
the way they're dealing with brexit
the way they're dealing with covet and
the way that the scottish people see
this current prime minister
um of kobe cases of course uh top of the
political gender uh for everyone
at the minute we saw of course those
record number of cases posted yesterday
because of a technical error
how concerned are you about the current
situation
well i think the common situation with
corbett i think the government have
messed it up they've wasted the summer
it's quite clear that tests and trace
isn't working properly the testing
system
is collapsing and indeed it may have
been a technical error but it's just
another error layered on top of all the
other problems with tests and trace and
i think if you look at what kier starmer
has said today
and in terms of the five-point plan to
try and get the country
back on even keel i think that's very
clear in terms of what needs to be done
we've got lots of areas in local
lockdown we've got confused messaging
we've got a prime minister that doesn't
know
what the messaging is we've got areas
like bury and bolton and bunny and
lockdown when in actual fact they have
at lower infection rates in our rates
than perhaps say oxbridge where the
prime minister's constituency
is and i think somebody said yesterday
an academic said you could drive 40
miles across the northwest of england
and go through four different areas
with four different covered restrictions
so we really need the government to
start showing us what the criteria is
for putting
areas into local lockdown what the
criteria is for bringing us out of local
lockdown
fixing tests and trades and really if
everyone wants to download the
covered apps in both scotland and those
apps should be able to you should be
able to pop in your postcode because the
app tells you where you are
and give you a list of the local
restrictions it seems strange that
newspapers and broadcasting outlets can
do this on their websites but the
government can't do it on their own app
so let's learn from some of the
countries has already been said like
germany
who's publishing the criteria for local
people to see and let's try and get the
country
out of this as quickly as possible with
a sensible government with a
communication strategy that doesn't seem
completely haphazard
remember um just finally
a book called left out released last
month revealed that you almost left the
labour party last year there was
actually a pitch review
rehearsing uh your speech uh at a launch
event of the independent group of course
seven
uh labour mps quit the party to form the
group apparently you pulled out at the
last minute
none of them are in parliament you're in
the shadow cabinet did you dodge a bit
of a bullet there
well i think i made the correct decision
to stay and i think over that period of
time many
people in the labour party whether it be
the plp or ordinary members
it looked very seriously whether or not
the labour party still held the values
that they held and
that was
speech actually it was just we were
giving bits of paper to see what we
would uh
what it would look like and what we
would do and i pulled out um
quite before the change uk people did
leave and i did change my mind because
of a number of reasons the labour party
across the united kingdom still the only
party that speaks for the whole of the
united kingdom
and is the only party that can deliver
the social change and the social justice
that i came into the labour party to do
i want to fight
against that inequality and against
poverty and the labour party can do that
i'm glad i stayed
and we're now under new leadership and
new management because stammer is doing
incredibly well i think the public are
starting to respond to that
i'm disappointed some people in the end
did leave and history will show that
they did it for the right reasons
and many people including in the
conservative party of course
and in other parties liberal democrats
millers really examined whether or not
they would stay in their parties over
that tomorrow's period
i made a decision to stay and i'm very
glad that i did